ich empfinde das als etwas sehr
wichtiges
weil rauchen eine private entscheidung
ist die gesundheitsgefährdend ist darauf
doch immer wieder hingewiesen auf den
muss und anderen dingen und wenn man das
machen möchte sollte man das tun finde
ich das kann jeder für sich entscheiden
aber im öffentlichen raum entscheide ich
das teilweise mit auch für andere und
ich habe es finde dass es als ziemlich
egoistisch und eben nur auf sich bezogen
denken dass das rauchen nicht nur stört
andere menschen sondern dass es auch
deren gesundheit und deswegen finde ich
es toll wenn das geregelt wird uns
verboten wird weil ich es einfach leid
bin durchaus sparten zu laufen
verschiedenste raucher die
verschiedenste dinge tun und ich damit
belästigt und belastet werden
also ich muss sagen ich bin für ein
generelles verbot vom rauchen
ob es jetzt im privatraum im pkw oder in
der öffentlichkeit ist es ist schon
längst an der zeit es wird in den
letzten jahren viel diskutiert über
feinstaub und wohl noch nicht mal
differenziert ist ob das jetzt vom motor
kommt oder vom bremsen
generell sollen pkw schon aus den
großstädten verschwinden beim rauchen
ist das ja erwiesen dass 70.000 leute
jährlich durch aktives rauchens sterben
dreitausend durch passiv rauchen nur in
der bundesrepublik und deshalb ist das
schon längst an der zeit es zu verbieten
es wird schon genug
seitens der politik in die
persönlichkeitsrechte der bürger
eingegriffen und jeder ist alt genug um
zu wissen kann ich hier rauchen kann ich
nicht rauchen in gaststätten verboten
das ist voll in ordnung dass da die
kippe nicht gezündet werden
aber wenn ich rauche wäre ich will noch
mal keiner würde ich sagen ein
glasklares nein für ein rauchverbot
generell dinge gibt die der umwelt mehr
schäden als zigarettenrauch
deswegen finde ich dass es jeder person
sich selbst überlassen sein sollte ob
man außen brauchen möchte oder nicht und
von daher finde ich dass das eigentlich
ein gesetzes was nicht wirklich viel
sinn hat weil die leute werden so oder
so tun
dadurch werden werden mehr
ordnungsgelder oder sowas doch oder was
auch immer angenommen werden und von
daher ist rentabel für den staat aber an
sich hat es nicht wirklich viel sein
ich halte sehr viel von einem generellen
rauchverbot auf öffentlichen plätzen und
straßen ich bin nichtraucher
darüber hinaus muss man sagen dass
dieses ständige rauchen von personen an
öffentlichen plätzen in cafés schon sehr
störend ist man kriegt regelmäßig auch
ab durch das rauchen werden die blutbahn
verengt die haut altert die lunge ganz
zu schreiben alles in einem dieses
rauchen ist doch die pure katastrophe
für jeden menschen